[Musique]
quand on porte l'uniforme les départs au
petit matin c'est une question
d'habitude la ville s'éveille la base
aérienne 125 Distre ne s'est jamais
assoupi les départs en mission c'est le
quotidien du militaire on va dire que
c'est plutôt fréquent par concernant là
je suis parti au Liban l'année dernière
donc de juin jusqu'à au mois de novembre
et là je repars du coup cette année donc
une petite année de de ri chez moi et je
repars quels sont les les sentiments
d'un militaire la proche d'embarquer
dans
l'avion les premières fois c'est un peu
stressant mais là c'est mon trè départ
donc Mo moins d'appréhension un peu plus
serein on attend toujours d'être dans
l'avion pour être s de bien partir on
sait jamais mais oui c'est on commence
en l'habitude avec un peu un peu
d'expérience
ok on est bon pour la
musette c'est tout bon pour moi je vous
laisse avancer tout droit s'il vous
plaît merci beaucoup il y a beaucoup de
personnes là ils partent pour où c'est
tous ces gens ils sont 205 et ils
partent pour la Roumanie c'est un volume
c'est un volume important oui c'est un
gros volume mais après c'est
relativement habituel pour nous est-ce
que l'activité s'est densifié ces
derniers temps oui tout à fait depuis
que Cray est descendu chez nous ça c'est
relativement inensifié puis avec les
événements qui se passent dans le monde
on a pas mal de
[Musique]
travail en H colonnes
Vicu si l'activité s'est densifiée c'est
que la base est devenue une plateforme
majeure de l'Armée de l'Air et de
l'Espace depuis plusieurs mois elle est
le principal point de part de tous les
militaires en
[Musique]
opération Istre est la plus grande base
aérienne de France on raconte qu'elle
était capable d'accueillir la navette
spatiale américaine grâce à sa piste de
5 km mais depuis plus d'un an la BA 125
comme l'appellent les aviateurs vit au
rythme d'un chantier
colossal bonjour ça va
bonjour la première difficulté dès le
départ c'était d'être en mesure de faire
transiter autant de passagers sur une
base qui par essence ne peut pas laisser
passer n'importe qui du coup il a fallu
imaginer ce terminal à cheval sur la
limite de la base pour être en mesure de
faire entrer les personnes de pouvoir
assurer leur filtrage et ensuite de
pouvoir les mener vers l'espace où ils
vont mener les procédures d'embarquement
d'accord et d'enregistrement donc là si
si vous voulez on va faire le finalement
le cheminement que feront les passagers
lorsquil viendront
embarquer dans ces murs le service
d'infrastructure de la défense a conçu
un nouveau terminal passager un projet
qui transforme la base aérienne en un
véritable roiss
militaire l'objet principal de ce
terminal c'est d'être en mesure de de
projeter plus de 100000 passagers par an
et de pouvoir affrter simultan
deux appareils de projection long
courrier donc plus de 540 passagers
simultanément la fonction c'est
également de pouvoir projeter tout types
de matériel pour cela on va énormément
augmenter notre capacité à traiter du
frit par voie aérienne puisque nous
allons passer d'environ 2000 tonnes par
an jusqu'en 2020 à plus de 9000 tonnes à
échéance 2024 et dans un 3è temps nous
devrons être en mesure de pouvoir
projeter tout type de munition et
d'explosion
et pour cela nous allons faire
construire à l'écart de toute habitation
et de tout bureau une zone qu'on appelle
Hute cargo dans laquelle nous allons
pouvoir conditionner tout type de de
munition et encore une fois et
d'explosifs pour pouvoir les transporter
par voie
[Musique]
aérienne donc comme je vous le disais
ici c'est la salle d'enregistrement donc
ce sera la salle d'attente quand les
gens arriveront peut-être un petit peu
en avance avant de prendre leur avion
pour vous c'est une très grosse
plusvalue opérationnelle pour la
projection des forces alors c'est très
grosse plusvalue parce que on gagne
énormément d'autonomie tout reposera
uniquement sur du personnel militair
avec des contrôleurs aériens militaires
du personnel au sol militaire et tout
sera internalisé et puis évidemment on
gagne sur le long terme d'un point de
vue financier puisque le être hébergé à
roissie Charles de Gaulle ça coûtait aux
armées environ 15 millions par an donc
en l'espace d'à peine 3 ans je dirais on
rentabilise l'investissement
d'infrastructure le carousel est pas
installé encore non bah on peut
peut-être aller directement au voir
lesag les
tribagages finalement dans
l'infrastructure on n'a pas l'habitude
de faire du tribagage des convoyeurs des
machines à rayon X c'est quelque chose
de de vraiment nouveau donc ici déjà on
a eu des contraintes techniques parce
qu'on a la charpente globale du bâtiment
il a fallu également mettre une nouvelle
charpente pour intégrer tout le système
tribagage et donc et là on est vraiment
sur les normes civiles internationales
pour permettre à un avion MRTT de
pouvoir atterrir dans n'importe quel
aéroport et de pouvoir surtout livrer
les bagages dans n'importe quel aéroport
on est quand même fier du résultat et on
espère enfin on espère avoir un très bon
rendu
prochainement la mise en service de ce
terminal est la dernière pièce d'un
programme d'infrastructure destiné à
renforcer la capacité d'intervention et
de projection de l'armée franç
à l'international l'escale de la BA 125
est entièrement dédié à cette mission
365 jours par
[Musique]
an aujourd'hui nous travaillons sur un
terminal aéroportuaire qui a été
construit dans les années 90 et pour
pouvoir embarquer du fret et des
passagers sur des procédures des années
90 sans forcément appliquer les normes
Schengen qui n'étaient pas appliqué au
militaire à cette époque-là le nouveau
terminal aéroport puaire lui répond à
toutes les normes actuelles pour pouvoir
embarquer dans des conditions
réglementaires et dans les meilleures
conditions d'accueil non militaires
demain l'ensemble des projections seront
effectué au départ de la base aérienne
et donc c'est bien tout ce volume qui
avant était réparti sur plusieurs bases
en France qui sera centralisé sur la
base a
indistre pour développer ces nouvelles
infrastructures la base aérienne
s'appuie sur les liens historiques
qu'elle entretient avec sa
ville les besoins de l'armée et la
technologie qui est prononcé aujourd'hui
trouve domicile ici et ça montre que
notre base je dirais est un élément
stratégie d'un défense nationale qu'elle
prend place encore plus dans
l'organisation militaire de l'OTAN et et
d'autres éléments qui sont décisifs pour
les théâtres guerriers et donc nous
effectivement nous sommes associés
heureux de l'être
depuis une dizaine d'années la
modernisation du parc aéronautique de
l'Armée de l'Air et de l'Espace a
accéléré la montée en puissance de la be
avec 15 appils groste
la5 ABR désormais la plus important
flotte militaire de ce type en
Europe les a de la base c'est lui les
aviateurs baptis du nom d'un oiseau
légendaire le phix SAF que cet oiseau
fait 60 m de long et presque 20 m de
haut
[Musique]
bonjour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
our parfait et c'est bon pour vous c'est
tout bon alors si on parle que des
capacités de ravitaillement ça tout
changer en fait parce qu'on a une
capacité d'emport de carburant qui est
largement supérieure à celle qu'on avait
sur Boeing avant le Boeing à titre
d'exemple on pouvait emmener dans les 85
90 tonnes de carburant mais il fallait
des conditions bien spécifiques pour les
emmener on il fallait que la température
soit basse que toutes les conditions
soient réunies pour pouvoir emmener ce
carburant avec cet avion on en mène pas
beaucoup plus finalement on en mène 109
tonnes mais on peut les emmener quoi
qu'il arrive quelle que soit la
température quel que soit longueur de
piste à pe de chose près ça va
fonctionner la grosse différence
également c'est que le on a apporté une
capacité de transport qu'on avait pas du
tout en tout cas pas à cette échelle sur
le Boeing on se retrouve à pouvoir
transporter du passager du FR
fairevacuation sanitair en même temps
qu'on fait du ravitaement en vol donc
est capable de faire toutes les missions
et de toutes les faire en même temps ce
qui est le gros changement qu' apporté
cet appareil CP à 9h 8h30 à
895 on a besoin de 5 4 ça n fait 5 t 5
d'extra
ouais je sais ce que
j' quelle quantité de de carburant tu
délivres et en combien de temps euh
alors ça va dépendre de de l'aéronef
qu'on a en général pour les rafales on
est quand même sur un plus gros débit on
est aux alentours de 1 tonne par minute
c'est pas une masse à faire parce que le
panier il est tout petit et le le
moindre petit écart la moindre petite
turbulence peut faire que le panier euh
part dans tous les sens et là ça devient
dangereux d'où ma place aussi dans
l'arvitaement c'est de garder
l'intégrité et des chasseurs et de notre
[Musique]
avion il y a quelques mois le Phénix a
participé à l'une des plus importantes
démonstrations de force de l'Armée de
l'Air et de l'Espace objectif être
capable d'intervenir en quelques heures
à autre bout du monde alors Pegas
c'était une une véritable opération
puisque nous avons 5 MRTT 10 rafales et
4 à 400 m qui sont partis de la basirien
Distre dans la nuit du 24 au 25 juin
2023 en fait le le but de cette de cette
manœuvre était de déployer dans des
délais contraints des forces dans la
zone Indo-Pacifique le dispositif s'est
scindé en deux boucles une boucle qui
est allée d'abord à Singapour puis sur
l'île de GAM et l'autre boucle qui est
allé en Malaisie avant finalement de
revenir en métropole via les Émirats
arabes unis finalement le MRTT est un
avion qui est encore assez euh qui est
qui est récent et donc l'intégration à
des coalitions la mise en place de
procédures communes était également un
des objectifs de de pégaz pour arriver
en zone Indo-Pacifique il a fallu moins
de 40 he donc on montre que finalement
dès qu'il va se passer quoi que ce soit
dans dans cette zone où la France a des
intérêt la France sera capable de se
déployer euh en masse avec des
ravitailleurs des avions de chasse et
également des avions de transport
tactique en en soutien pour pour
finalement parer à toute à toute crise
potentielle pour conduire la
métamorphose de la base le colonel
anlord Michel un nouveau défi dans le
parcours de celle qui était l'une des
premières femmes en France à devenir
pilote de chasse sur Mirage on peut voir
que l'actualité internationale est assez
riche avec des bouleversements quel
effet cela a ou a eu sur votre base j'ai
coutume de dire que notamment grâce à
cet avion qu'on voit derrière nous le
MRTT Phenix et bien la base RN 125 est
est au cœur de toute l'actualité
opérationnelle euh malheureusement ce
qui se passe en Israël aujourd'hui ce
qui s'est passé au Niger et qui a encore
des conséquences aujourd'hui toutes ces
missionsl et bien la base aéenne 1225 y
participe rapatrier les ressortissants
déployer des forces en mission
ravitailler des avions de combat qui
vont protéger les espaces aériens on y
participe est-ce que colonel pourraz
revenir sur cette mission justement de
la dissuision quiass sur votre base
effectivement la la mission de
dissuasion nucléaire c'est la mission
principale de notre base aérienne dite à
vocation nucléaire c'est-à-dire que sur
cette base aérienne sont mis en œuvre
des moyens aériens qui permettent de
garantir la crédibilité de la France en
terme de dissuasion nucléaire on sait
depuis malheureusement le déclenchement
du conflit en Ukraine que ce volet
dissuasion est
particulièrement regardé d'un point de
vue politique de la part de nos
compétiteurs et que cela nous oblige à
être très crédiible sur ce volet donc
cette base s'entraîne presque tous les
jours avec un haut niveau d'engagement à
préparer cette mission et et j'insiste
un petit peu sur le fait que nous sommes
la composante visible de la dissuasion
nucléaire c'est-à-dire que c'est c'est
un mot qui pourrait paraître peu secret
mais on montre qu'on s'entraîne on
montre qu'on est préparé et qu'on a des
moyens qui sont extrêmement
opérationnels pour réaliser cette
mission quatre fois par an l'Armée de
l'Air et de l'Espace réalise un raide
nucléaire une opération nocturne
baptisée poker et qui n'a rien un bluff
en 2020 pour la première fois les forces
aériennes stratégiques décident de
réaliser cette opération en plein jour
cette année-là le ciel français désert
le confinement a cloué au sol toutes les
activités aéronautiques après 21 ans de
service le capitaine Pierre est l'un des
pilotes les plus expérimentés de son
escadre c'est une rare opération qui a
lieu sur le territoire national qui est
une opération de dissuision nucléaire où
quatre fois par an on démontre à
d'éventuels agresseurs et à nos nos
alliés que nous sommes crédibles dans la
dissuision nucléaire et que si l'ordre
nous était donné de la mettre en œuvre
on serait capable de le faire alors nous
on a on a un double rôle on a déjà le
rôle de plateforme de communication donc
le but ça sera de pouvoir faire une
plateforme de communication avec les
états-majors et parce que l'ordre arrive
directement du président ensuite dans le
cas de la dissuision nucléaire notre but
est de pouvoir frapper là où on va nous
le demander quel que soit l'endroit et
ça peut être des endroits très lointains
et donc du coup l'avion ravita tailleur
devient essentiel pour la manœuvre des
avions de chasse
[Applaudissements]
c'est une opération où nous on va jouer
le fait que le Président de la
République nous engage donc on va
recevoir un ordre de de départ queon va
mettre en œuvre le but est décoller le
plus rapidement possible au niveau
aviation de chasse on va y mettre
énormément de moyens parce qu'on va voir
les avions qui vont participer au raid
avec nous et les avions qui vont nous
faire opposition pour nous empêcher de
passer depuis tout juste 60 ans les
aviateurs sont en alerte permanente au
service de la dissuision nucléaire la
première fois c'était un 8 octobre
1964 la première prise d'alerte des face
donc moment où on est devenu autonome au
niveau politique et ben en fait les
avions ravitailleurs à cette époque là
étaient déjà présents ils ont participé
à la première prise d'alerte avec le
binôme historique qu'il est resté très
longtemps mirage 4 et c'est 135 fr à
l'époque mais effectivement de depuis 60
ans h 24 tout temps tout lieu on assure
une une permanence pour la dissuasion
[Musique]
nucléaire à l'abri des regards le
capitaine Thomas et ses hommes sont les
angesgardiens discrets de la base
aérienne l'escadron de défense sol air
est capable d'intercepter toutes les
menaces venues du ciel le conflit en
Ukraine a remis en ses capacités des
armées françaises alors la dernière loi
de programmation militaire prévoit un
investissement de 5 milliards d'euros
dans ce secteur on se retrouve face à
des menaces potentielles où il y a en
face de nous une aviation robuste qui
nécessite potentiellement le déploiement
de de système de défense solaire le
mamba est à neutraliser à peu près tout
types de menac que ce soit missile drone
avion gros porteur avion de chasse ça
sert à protéger les forces déployées ça
sert à protéger les grands événements
sur le territoire national ça sert
également à protéger les bases aériennes
notamment ici sur la base aérienne à
vocation nucléaire donc on a plusieurs
types de mission sur le territoire
national comme en opération extérieure à
l'instar de la Roumanie où on est
actuellement déployé pour protéger le
flan est des pays de l'OTAN à quelques
pas de là le capitaine Thomas veut nous
montrer une arme d'un tout autre genre
c'est l'autre enseignement de la guerre
en Ukraine la menace drone est en train
de changer l'art de la guerre ok on a en
tracking une de là on essaie de
reprendre le drone et il vole beaucoup
plus lentement on le met en tracking en
tracking ça veut dire la caméra le suit
sans qu'on ait besoin de bouger
manuellement c'est dire c'est la caméra
par des les capteurs avec les capteurs
en fait il va il va suivre le drone à la
trace vas-y double C ouais voilà c'est
bon ok en gros touche à rien là s lâche
le
joystick la caméra
elle suit le
drone la caméra va nous proposer
plusieurs PL qui pour potentiellement
être un drone c'est-à-dire ils vont tout
ce qui a des hélices tout ce qui tourner
tout ce qui va voler donc des fois ils
peuvent nous proposer des oiseaux c'est
pour ça que l'opérateur il est important
parce que c'est lui qui va décider si
c'est un drone ou pas après suite à ça
on est en capacité de pouvoir les
détecter et les intercepter en fonction
des différents systèmes et là notamment
avec le système basal nous on va
vraiment identifier la menace et rendre
compte pour que l'officier prenne la
décision là c'est le l'opérateur ça va
être une question de rapidité et de de
clairvaillance dans la prise de décision
pour rendre compte directement à
l'officier de supervision 200 m ok j'ai
un numéro de série il se dirige vers le
point à défendre donc on est autorisé à
ok je l'ai en tracking lancer la
procédure de
brouillage bien reçu système basalt
c'est un ensemble de systèmes qui permet
de connecter différents senseurs pour
détecter les menaces la principale
menace actuelle qui est la menace mini
drone donc vous avez pour cela plusieurs
senseurs du radar de laagoniométrie qui
va permettre de faire de l'écoute de
fréquence une caméra qui peut faire une
acquisition visuelle et également le
dispositifs infodrone qui permet de
détecter les drones qui sont équipés des
puces infodrone alors une fois que le
drone a été détecté identifié et
classifié on peut lancer une procédure
de brouillage tout va dépendre des
consignes opérationnelles qui nous sont
données si ce drone est à l'extérieur de
la zit donc de la Zone Interdite il n'y
aura pas de procédure de brouillage
néanmoins s'il pénètre la zone interdite
et qu'il se dirige vers le point à
défendre là nous serons en mesure de le
brouiller s'il n'est pas autorisé et
pour moi il en altitude il est au sol
est
posé l'intérêt de l'armée de l'air c'est
d'agréger tous les acteurs inter
ministériel et interarmé et pouvoir
coordonner l'ensemble de l'emploi des
moyens de lutte
[Rires]
antidrone
avertisseur sonore prévient un message
autorisé détecé position de l'antenne
positionte I et information on a le
modèle D phant
idention
par
P
intertioné l anone est une permanente à
l'innovation alors la be aérienne
veutêtre en première ligne dans la
recherche de nouvell
solution matin les équipes de protection
de la be expériment un nouveau système
de
[Musique]
détectional d'autres types
DRC
maison
aujourd'hui on a que la détection mais
ils ont aussi une capacité de brouillage
qui sera testé ultérieurement de ce qu'
nous ont dit aujourd'hui il peuvent même
brouiller précisément un drone plutôt
qu'envoyer un cône il focalise sur le
drone parce qu'il capte la fréquence du
drone il brouille que cette fréquence ok
ramène le drone et début du boucl sur
100 m c'est
parti il y a des missions qui
n'attendent pas et d'autres dont
l'attente fait partie de la mission 24h/
24 des aviateurs veillent sur l'espace
aérien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
français le DAL le feu la trappe est
fermée les sondes V obstruer pas d' SF
le radome la pointe le radome en bon
état la perche de ravitaillement les
sondes dans obstru le feu le dalle le LM
en sécu déverrouillé hors connexion
vont pas de PO dur pas de
fuite pas de point dur pas de fuite la
dérive on est bien en sécu il y a pas de
fuite antenne en bon
état rien dans le moteur rien dans la
poubelle et enau fix SCU cross en V
robinet ouvert il est en sécu et il est
plein les trappes sont fermées la
trappette additionnelle la BBM rien dans
l'entrée derrière bien la sonde et rien
dans le piège à gauche limite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci on a des appareils qui sont prêts
au au quatre coins de la France pour
faire à la fois une mission de police de
ciel on va venir contrôler des avions
qui peuvent bah être en infraction ou
porter assistance à des avions en panne
ou perdu mauvaise météo et choses comme
ça on est deux pilotes un pilote
d'alerte l'autre qui est en soutien et
qui va a passé d'alerte quand le premier
sera déclenché et donc pendant ce
temps-là bah lui il peut effectivement
faire du sport ou s'occuper à côté tout
en restant bah disponible on est dans
une zone normalement qui est fermée où
on vit entre nous pendant une semaine
comme ça dès que le klaxon retentit
normalement tout le monde l'entend et et
tout le monde se met BR de combat
d'accord c'est c'est quelque chose qui
est qui est fréquent alors des
alertes réel il y en a il y en a
beaucoup pas quotidiennement mais mais
quasiment mais qui peuvent être du
simple avion de ligne en panne radio qui
répond plus pendant X minutes ou le
petit avion de tourisme qui a décollé
pour faire campagne et qui se retrouve
bloqué audessus d'une couche de nuage
qui n'arrive pas à rentrer après on
avait suivi il y a quelques quelques
mois l'appareil qui avait été intercepté
en train de larguer des paquets de de
drogue voilà ça c'est plus exceptionnel
quand même heureusement donc la majorité
des cas c'est des choses plutôt de
l'assistance
[Musique]
la fin de la métamorphose de la base
confirme la place primordiale qu'elle
occupe dans l'histoire de l'aéronautique
Istre est depuis toujours une terre
d'aviation ici le monde se divise en
deux catégories ceux qui volent et ceux
qui rêvent de
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voler